the world's richest man has been on a
charm offensive inside Twitter HQ
meeting a lot of cool people he said
having coffee with staff but any idea
that this deal would be drama-free was
shattered within hours when Elon Musk
sacked three top Executives musk's
takeover hadn't even been officially
announced when Twitter's chief executive
Chief Financial Officer and head of
legal Affairs were shuttled from this
building and told not to return it is a
power move and a sign of just how
fundamentally he plans to change things
here the bird has been freed musk
tweeted he says he wants to make Twitter
the world's digital Town Square I didn't
do it because it would be easy he
tweeted I didn't do it to make more
money I did it to try and help Humanity
whom I love
musk has also hinted he will open
Twitter back up to the former president
Donald Trump some fear the billionaire
will reduce content moderation on
Twitter when abuse is still Rife
but he isn't short of fans in his new
neighborhood I think it's the greatest
thing since sliced bread really yeah
huge fan of them I think he'll do great
things it's long overdue I think he'll
get Twitter in in China and that's a big
Market
um he's had a lot of success in China
with Tesla
musk himself says he overpaid for
Twitter at 44 billion dollars but
believes he can bring half the world
onto his website Elon Musk seems to be
focusing on the idea of making Twitter
more free speech in his words what do
you make of that I thought it was really
interesting that one of his first
messages was to the advertisers of
Twitter
um and to say kind of don't worry too
much because if it becomes this Cesspool
of kind of hate and uh other undesirable
content advertisers are going to go away
so I think he said some of those things
but he's going to confirm confront the
reality of trying to attract more
advertisers
this takeover completes a seven month
long will he won't he Saga even by
musk's Mercurial standards it's been
perplexing what happens next though is
even harder to predict
[Applause]